buongiorno
tutti noi siamo due artisti
gli architetti designers
la professione facciamo cose molto
normale disegniamo lampade mobili in
termini mostre e qualche architettura
però durante tutta la nostra vita
professionale ci dedichiamo anche a fare
alcune riflessioni che poi mettiamo
anche sulla carta cerchiamo di
rappresentare magari anche in occasione
di qualche mostra eccetera per cui
racconteremo oggi questa casa liberata e
cercheremo di far capire che cosa vuol
dire attraverso questi cinque progetti
che hanno diverse scale si sono progetti
sperimentali non hanno diciamo l'idea di
essere applicati immediatamente quindi
volte parliamo di fisica teorica e
ricchezze che applicata questi sono
diciamo studio l'abitare come fenomeno
il tema della casa tra auto e diventato
il grande attualità nell'ultimo decennio
con la crisi finanziaria fenomeni nuovi
o moto urgenti come l'immigrazione le
nuove povertà
la crisi stessa e ceto medio che è
troppo ricca per chiedere una casa
popolare ma è troppo povera invece per
acquistare una casa dal libero mercato
quindi questa domanda di abitazione del
2000 negli ultimi decenni estremamente
frammentata segmentata e mutevole quindi
sono condizioni nuove che richiedono le
risposte non solo quantitativi ma anche
qualitativi e quindi molto differenti da
quell'idea di housing sociale che era
nata negli anni sessanta settanta che
era basata sullo standard quindi su
livelli una casa per tutti adesso il
tema è una casa per ciascuno una casa
per ciascuno sa dove la reversibilità la
flessibilità la mobilità la mutevolezza
del
l'assetto della casa stessa e il tema
centrale come nei nostri progetti di
ricerca
prima di questo progetto sviluppato
qualche anno fa perché abbiamo chiamato
conta cronica assieme architetto andrea
branzi poi cercavamo deve assumere un po
questi concetti che stava dicendo
appunto giovanni mobilità reversibilità
no qui cerchiamo di fare è un modello
quasi di metropoli un modello di una
città un pensiero sulla città che noi
chiamiamo debole chiamiamo molto diffusa
è una specie di grande campagna potrebbe
essere la pianura padana una pianura
dell'olanda e qui vediamo questo
territorio cablato con questi con questi
pilastri dove alcuni elementi
architettonici architettonici scorrono e
si muovono proprio un po come l'opposto
della città che abbiamo oggi invece in
cemento in pietra stabile e durevole
negli anni un po segue appunto il
modello dell'agricoltura nel modello
delle colture che io semino una volta
una coltura e poi dopo qualche anno la
cambio ecco un po seguiva un po questo
tipo di modello estremamente dal nostro
punto di vista nuovo innovativo poi c'è
poi tutto il desiderio di vivere della
natura che ha poi una delle grandi dei
grandi sogni della modernità
d'altra parte voleva anche superare
quello che è lo zoo ning forse per molti
di voi non sanno cos'è ma anche questa è
uno dei grandi concetti che si è
sviluppato appunto nel secolo scorso c'è
la divisione della città per aree
omogenee la città moderna nasce un po
così c'è la città dello shopping in
città del tempo libero
la città dove si produce è una città
dove si vive che è poi all opposto un po
della città ibrida della città
preindustriale appunto prima della
rivoluzione industriale questa agronica
in certo qual modo vuole tornare ad un
modello del genere cioè proprio aribri
dare praticamente tutte le nostre
attività
il negozio che ritorna sotto casa
l'artigiano
nella piazzetta fianco eccetera e non
questa città divisa per attività
omogenee la fine dello zone di questo
teorema paradigma moderno
qui è visibile a livello di scala
territoriale quindi con questa
compenetrazione tra città e campagna tra
spazi dedicati alla residenza e alla
produzione ma è anche una condizione
nuova che noi abbiamo cercato di creare
all'interno della casa stessa
quindi una casa dove vedrete nelle
immagini non ci sono più dei muri delle
stanze che definiscono un assetto
definitivo è definito dell'abitazione ma
ci sono degli spazi compattati degli
spazi compattati sono degli armate in
realtà dove vengono compattati e
funzioni tecnologie e comportamenti in
questo video siberiano come tutti questi
oggetti da oggetti della vita quotidiana
vanno a finire in queste scatole no un
po quello che è successo con questo tipo
di oggetti qui dentro in un unico
oggetto abbiamo una telecamera ma con
una macchina fotografica un telefono una
mail
ci sono un sacco di cose qua dentro ed è
una delle strategie
no questa compattazione ave va avanti da
anni ed è usata in tantissimi prodotti
qui abbiamo provato applicarla appunto
alla casa per cui cosa è successo sono
questi che vedete sono degli specie di
armadi sono simili nel funzionamento ai
mobili delle farmacie cioè io ho una
pianta che forse ora vediamo
immaginiamo un appartamento anche
abbastanza piccolo un 8x8 dove nelle
pareti ci sono ci sono questi armadi che
io posso o noleggiare o comprare a
seconda della composizione del nucleo
familiare magari sono un singolo sono
una coppia e estraggo praticamente le
mie stanze mobili perché poi cosa sono
poi questi questi oggetti è un po
difficile da capire che aveva mai ladra
sono a metà tra un mobile è uno spazio
sono dei mobili abitabili
come si vede dalla pianta o dalle foto
successive di volta in volta estrarrò lo
spazio di quello necessità e la casa
diventa tutta quanta una stanza da letto
tutta quanta una stanza studio oppure
mettere lazio delle stanze dei momenti
della vita che normalmente invece non
hanno una connessione in una planimetria
tradizionali di abitazione questa teoria
della compattare fa parte comunque dalla
tradizione anche se è uno dei paradigmi
moderni l'existence pini ma non ha
nient'altro che la ricerca di spazi
minimi di luoghi minimi che serviva
perché la riabilitazione molto economica
nel nostro caso diciamo quest'idea di
compattare non serve per un'economia
diciamo di tipo monetario ma per creare
invece uno spazio disponibile un vuoto
potenziale un voto sempre il libro non
progettato quindi che serve per gli
attitudini per per quello che serviranno
il futuro diciamo per la potenzialità
del divenire piuttosto che definire la
casa sono delle cose delle necessità e
definitive c'è anche qui no una specie
di d d di rottura no di questo di questa
idea dello zoom in gol come la città che
divideva la citta punto in zone omogenee
la casa anche l'abbiamo abbastanza da
letto abbiamo il bagno il living
eccetera
questa è diventata una specie anche una
metafora ad esempio di quello che accade
nel nostro un nostro modi o monitor i
nostri delle nostre attività diventano
delle specie di file che posso aprire e
addirittura far interagire in maniera
sempre assolutamente libero quindi in
un'asta in sostanza una casa moto più
autobiografica che può cambiare nel
corso del tempo a seconda delle
necessità che si verranno a creare
ecco questo è un po lo stesso discorso
solo che sale di scala ad una scala
quasi diciamo architetturale una specie
di condominio qui vediamo in questo
piccolo video molto elementare che di
solito è un'architettura c'è un hardware
che appunto fatta dalle travi pilastri
verso lete eccetera
e poi ci sono tutta una serie di
attività che vengono messe
successivamente una specie di che noi
chiamiamo punto software
questi in queste griglie noi mettiamo i
nostri oggetti che ci aiutano appunto a
fare le nostre attivi è ancora ripresa
della monda elettronica cioè l'idea che
c'è un computer che riempì poi di
software di applicazioni
seconda dell'uso che ne vuoi fare quindi
non c'è una tecnologia che da un uso
definitivo ed è finito ma sono le
applicazioni e software che creeranno
diciamo l'utilizzo reale della macchina
questa vida catalogo vedete vede delle
scaffolding diciamo un grande una grande
struttura che viene riempita da spazi
verticali in maniera verticale a secondo
diciamo delle necessità potrò comporli
una casa vedete con un giardino
personale il social o bill e il
giardinaggio con quattro stanze da letto
se mi piace dormire con tre stanze da
per cucinare se mi piace cucinare quindi
una casa anche qui dove non c'è uno zoo
ning una identità definitiva ma la
possibilità di rendere molto più vicina
alle nostre esigenze i nostri desideri
compongo la casa così come faccio
shopping comprando noleggiando spazi e
servizi proprio un po la logica del
prodotto nella stessa maniera in cui
prodotto mi da questa enorme libertà di
cambiarlo di sostituirlo di noleggiarlo
secondo appunto delle mie condizioni
molto diverse di vita
ecco qui abbiamo provato a rendere un po
la casa alla stessa con la stesso tipo
di libertà e di reversibilità
questa è un'altra
un altro esercizio un'altra riflessione
oggi chiaramente il mondo dei servizi
sviluppatissimo no è il nuovo i nuovi
prodotti
anche noi desire incominciamo a
disegnare proprio disegnare anche dal
punto di vista estetico nuovi prodotti
servizi
abbiamo provato immaginare cosa vuol
dire avere una casa una casa vicina a
questo a questo tipo di strategie
no la possibilità ad esempio di non
comprare quasi niente non possedere ma
accede accedere alle cose accedere alle
funzioni per cui devo dormire qualcuno
mi metterà a disposizione un letto
devono mangiare alla stessa maniera un
po come in ufficio quando prendiamo un
caffè caldo non è che ci preoccupiamo di
andare a prendere la caf comprare la
caffettiera una cucina a gas riempire la
caffettiera no ma ci sono già delle
macchinette che noi compriamo vengono
fornite da fornitori di servizi e e
consumiamo il nostro caffè caldo così
come la coca cola fresca e cesa senza
preoccuparci di andare a comprare ogni
volta un frigorifero oppure un una
macchinetta del caffè ecco immaginare
una casa impostata in questo modo anche
qui davanti si vede questa cavallina
margine terrifica allucinante dove lo
stencil sostituito da questi numeri
verdi per accedere a punto a servizi ed
è però ho una casa veramente liberata
liberata dalla renault è chiaramente
dall'architettura che impone uno stile
una casa senza stile quindi lo stile
sarà dato dei prodotti in qualche modo
liberata anche che dà una dimensione
patrimoniale
quindi non investe soldi in tecnologie
obsolescenti così come faccio anche un
auspicio diceva dante e non compie il
computer ma contro un contratto diciamo
di servizio di assistenza che mi
rifornisce di oltre i bot a tecnologie
attuali sempre atleti ed accedere
eccetera
quindi tutte le mie risorse finanziare
in andranno non è comprare quello che mi
serve
nel comprare quello che mi piace e
quindi immagini precedente si vedevano
vasi cinesi quadri antichi quindi
piuttosto che comprare i frigoriferi o
lettini cucce per cani compro quello che
veramente mi perché poi quando compro un
frigorifero poi alla fine dopo 5 6 7
anni ad esempio questa è una
implicazione interessante di questa casa
servizio e che il frigorifero non è mio
ma ritorna all'azienda che me l'ha
venduta mela che mi sa che me l'ha
fornito per cui c'è tutta anche una
implicazione sulla sul ciclo di vita del
prodotto che se invece a miglio lo
prendo lo porto in discarica con tutte
le problematiche che ci sono nella
separazione dei materiali eccetera
eccetera
questo ad esempio un frigorifero
interessante è una specie di 48 ore una
specie di trolley che noleggia
supermercato per me per i miei surgelati
la mia birra fresca eccetera lo porto a
casa mi è fornito dal supermercato e è
praticamente lo plug go e diventa il mio
frigorifero magari per un single sono la
famiglia magari ne ho bisogno di cinque
borse
questo l'ultimo invece esercizio teorico
o sperimentale è un intero condominio
costruito invece su questa logica di
spazi accessori una casa cosiddetta
estesa a fronte quindi gli spazi gli
standard molto piccoli
in dotazione a ciascun abitante ci sono
invece degli spazi accessori che
scorrono lungo le facciate che possono
essere chiamati prenotati quindi on
demand e che ampiano in qualche modo
quindi la funzionalità della casa posso
chiamarmi in casa quindi una pizzeria un
luogo di culto un giardino una gelateria
un non mi ricordo che altro c'era un
mcdonald's per vedere quindi liliana la
partita di calcio sono tutte cose che
vorremmo avere nelle nostre piccole case
è però somma per avere tutto ci vorrebbe
una visione è fantastico se io stasera
una cenetta interessante eccomi e vorrei
farlo ad esempio fuori perché mira d
estate sono comportamenti 3 noto il mio
giardinetto all amia chioschetto o se
voglio fare un bagno in una bella
jacuzzi tutti i comportamenti game e
rendere sono relegate nell'ambito del
lusso che non ci possiamo permettere che
invece qui vengono realizzate con questo
sistema meccanizzato che è simile a
quello là del dello stoccaggio delle
merci a casa questo stagione merci però
si vedeva anche quell'omino questo
contadino che tornava la campagna sul
cervello che in effetti è un po la nuova
dimensione vogliamo dare nelle
tecnologie
da una parte ci sono le nuove teorie
alla tesi la possibilità di tornare
indietro a un mondo pre moderno quasi
dove ci sono più spazi commerciali
relegate nelle periferie dei centri
commerciali ma scazzi commerciali che ha
in casa che già attualmente non torno in
casa noi con i gruppi d'acquisto con il
door to door
quindi è un mix tra nuove tecnologie e
nuovi concetti di benessere che si
riferiscono a un mondo pre moderno
chiara real mille